let's now talk about the possible
outcomes to the 2022 midterm election
there are four possible outcomes to the
midterms that are now just a few weeks
away
three of the outcomes are really pretty
bad
so let's explore what these outcomes are
we have control of the house up for
grabs and control of the Senate up for
grabs if we look at the latest 538
forecasts uh Democrats are by a roughly
two to one margin favor to win the
Senate okay roughly by a two to one
margin favor to win in the Senate and if
you look at the House Republicans are by
a greater than two to one margin favored
to win the house so the if we want to
put numbers to this there's a roughly 70
percent chance that Republicans win the
house and of roughly 67 percent chance
that Democrats win the Senate so you
essentially have four possible outcomes
imagine a two by two grid Democrats
could win both the House and Senate
Republicans could win both the House and
Senate you could have Democrats win the
house but lose the Senate you could have
Democrats win the Senate but lose the
house those are the four scenarios so
let's do some simple probability math
these should add up to 100 these are the
four possible outcomes and we're going
to do these in order of likelihood and
then you have the following based on the
538 projections
the the most likely outcome is Democrats
win the Senate and Republicans win the
house that's 46 percent you've got a 24
chance that the Republicans win both
you've got a 20 chance that Democrats
win both and then you've got a 10 chance
that Democrats win the house but
Republicans win the Senate that's the
least likely outcome so let's start with
the least likely and work up
if Democrats win the house and
Republicans win the Senate it's not
going to happen but it would mean that
Democrats pass a ton of stuff in the
house that Joe Biden wants and basically
none of it gets past the Senate it's a
done deal it's really good for
republicans in 2024 they can say look
um they had the house and the White
House they proposed nothing reasonable
the senate had to block the stuff they
wanted to do vote for republicans in
2024. okay next scenario is that
Democrats win both this is the best
outcome quite frankly there's only a 20
percent chance of that now in this
scenario the Senate margin is not 60 40
meaning that it remains like the last
two years a lot of stuff you need 60
votes in order to pass so Democrats if
they held both the House and Senate
would be able to get some things done
Republicans would have struck them the
senate for everything that requires 60
votes they would claim these Democrats
are so extreme in what they propose we
have no choice choice next scenario in
order of likelihood going up is
Republicans take the house and the
Senate now that's also not the most
likely scenario it's obviously
disastrous nothing will get done for two
years if Republicans take both they will
try to blame Biden even though it is
their obstruction that will prevent
anything from getting done they will say
we had no choice everything Biden and
the Democrats put forward was so extreme
that we had to block it it will give
them a good setup for 2024 including to
actually try to influence the election
Itself by all sorts of subterfuge and
arguably illegal means the most likely
outcome a plurality is that Democrats
win the Senate
and Republicans win the house there's a
nearly 50 percent chance of that
particular individual result
in that scenario Republicans will stop
things in the house Democrats will
control the Senate but will have no
super majority and it will mean that
almost nothing happens Biden will be
blamed Democrats will be blamed and then
Republicans will use it to their
advantage in 2024. so what has to happen
obviously we should not concede the
house but the math of it is very much
not in the favor of Democrats so the
scenario
that is the most likely is Democrats
keep the Senate by a small margin but
lose the house
what we need to see is some of the
gubernatorial races go to the Democratic
candidate because ultimately you are
going to have I believe very little
accomplished during the next two years
thanks to Republicans taking the house
and then you will have a 2024 election
which may come down to governors in key
States potentially stealing electoral
votes Pennsylvania is a huge issue where
Josh Shapiro has to beat off a challenge
from Doug mastriano who he will try to
steal the Pennsylvania electoral votes
for the Republican nominee we know that
so Josh Shapiro's got a win in
Pennsylvania in Arizona this radical big
lie purveyor Kerry lake is currently
winning by a little bit Arizona is
another important state where if you
have a republican governor who is a full
big lie proponent
she may try to steal the Arizona
electoral votes for the Republican
candidate even if they don't actually
win the popular vote in that state so I
believe that the most likely scenario
here is Democrats keep the Senate lose
the house and the next two years will
ultimately conclude with do Democrats
control enough Governor's houses
that they can prevent the theft of the
2024 election if the Democratic
candidate is to win it's also possible
that the next two years are so
disastrous that a Republican president
legitimately wins in 2024. we can't deal
with that now what we can deal with is
who do we vote for in just three and a
half weeks I think roughly three two and
a half weeks three and a half weeks and
these are the four scenarios let me know
your thoughts we will have this and all
of our other Clips on our Instagram
which you can find at davidpackman show
one of our sponsors today is blue chew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month's supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence when
it's time all you have to do is take a
short quiz on their website a licensed
doctor approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of Bluetooth tablets are made in the
USA the entire process is just a few
clicks go to bluetooth.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code Pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping